لابد للداخل الى مدينه غريان جنوب غرب
طرابلس ان يمر بسوقها الرئيسي لبيع الخزف
والفخار والصناعات اليدويه التقليديه
فقدت هذه الحرفه زخمها مع الوقت
مؤخرا واجهت عشرات المصانع نقصا كبيرا في
المواد الاساسيه لصناعه الفخار والخزف
وخطر الاندثار بات يهدد هذه الصناعه ممكن
50 مصنع اصغرهم ماني في السن والباقي كله
قصدي خمس سنين ست سنين تاني مهناش من يخش
الخدمه في هبه مشاكل بالنسبه للوقود
النافطه
الطين عندنا عجز الطين بشكل لا يوصف
ارتباط غريان تاريخيا بصناعه الخزف
والفخار تؤكده حفريات يؤثر عليها بين حين
واخر يرجع بعضها الى الحقبه الرومانيه على
الاراضي الليبيه قبل اكثر من الفي عام
اساسا بلد الطين بالاسم الامازيغي القديم
بلد الطين ومنها اشتقت هذه الحرفه الانسان
ابن بيئتها فاشتقوا من الطين حرفتهم
اليدويه اللي عاشوا منها خلال السنين
الماضيه تشكل صناعه الخزف والفخار
والصناعات التقليديه بشكل عام جزءا من
هويه مدينه غريان وثقافه اهلها لكن مركز
التدريب الخاصه بهذه الصناعات والذي يضمن
استمرارها للاجياد القادمه يواجه تحديات
عده
في غريان مركز حكومي هو الوحيد على مستوى
البلاد للتدريب على الصناعات التقليديه
بجميع انواعها
توقف التدريب في هذا المركز منذ سنوات
بسبب قله الامكانيات والمواد الخام
والايدي العامله
والات المصنع الخاص بالمركز مثلا تفتقد
معايير السلامه الحديثه اذ صنعت في
ثماننيات القرن الماضي
ضغوطات بلديه من من الناس من الشارع نبي
نخدم موظفين
يعني
مدربين عالم يديروا حل
في غريان تتوارث الاسر مهنه الاشتغال
بصناعه الفخار والخزف والمنسوجات اليدويه
لكن تسويق هذه الصناعات التقليديه يواجه
تحديات عده ابرزها دخول صناعات مماثله من
خارج البلاد الى السوق المحليه احمد خليفه
الجزيره غريان